[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues les
français ont décidé en élisant leur
député à l'assemblée nationale de priver
le président de la république de
majorité absolue notre assemblée
aujourd'hui à l'image de notre pays
fracturé avoir voulu dissoudre des
clivages politiques par des débauchages
individuels
north a consisté au final qu'à remettre
au goût du jour la vieille recette de la
petite soupe sur le petit réchaud
dénoncé en son temps par le général de
gaulle mais n'aura pas permis de relever
le défi essentiel enrayer le déclin de
la france cette petite soupe nous n'en
voulons pas notre responsabilité est
clair ni compromission ni petits
arrangements avec un président de la
république dont nous contestons les
orientations chancelante depuis 2010 est
sur la dette sur l'énergie sur la
souveraineté agricoles et industriels
sur la sécurité sur l'immigration sur la
transition écologique mais jamais de
blocage stérile nous n'avons pas
l'intention de tous paralysés alors que
notre pays a déjà pris 30 ans de retard
faute d'une vision claire et d'une
action résolue nous ferons tout pour que
les cinq prochaines années soit plus
utile à notre nation que l'ont été les
10 dernières nous avons pour boussole le
bien commun de la france et des français
dès qu il en sera question nous serons
au rendez vous oui nous sommes prêts à
voter tous les textes qui iront dans le
sens du sursaut national celui du
pouvoir d'achat par le travail de la
reconstruction de notre appareil
industriel de la sanction des
délinquants ou de l'accès à la santé
mais pour que la france retrouve la
maîtrise son destin nous vous engageons
madame la première ministre à une
franche rupture avec la politique du
chien crevé au fil de l'eau il est temps
de répondre à l' attente légitime
d'autorité dans notre pays
d'autorité du savoir et de l'enseignant
à l'école d'autorité des policiers dans
nos quartiers d'autorité de la loi et de
la sanction vis-à-vis des délinquants
d'autorité de nos frontières face à des
flux migratoires qui déborde de nos
capacités d'assimilation
l'humiliation qu'a représenté pour les
français la chienlit du stade de france
est un énième symptômes de l'alarmante
déliquescence de l'autorité dans notre
pays nous vous appelons en prendre la
mesure et à prendre les décisions qui
s'imposent
si vous êtes disposé à construire assez
de places de prison nettement plus que
les 2000 places supplémentaires de la
dernière mandature vous pouvez compter
sur nous si vous êtes disposé instaurer
des peines minimales exemplaire pour
enfin sanctionné les délinquants vous
pouvez compter sur nous si vous êtes
disposé à plafonner strictement
l'immigration en fonction de nos
capacités d'amis d'assimilation vous
pouvez compter sur nous si vous êtes
disposé à expulser les étrangers fiché
pour radicalisation terroristes vous
pouvez compter sur nous
nous devons sûr qu aussi et peut-être
surtout répondre à cette exigence de
justice sociale la plus élémentaire
pouvoir vivre dignement de son travail
un coût de chaque à crédit de dépenses
sociales incontrôlée vous avez fait
croire que l'assistanat était la
solution alors qu'il n'est qu'illusion
plutôt que de multiplier les chèques
d'argent public tâchant de réduire
l'écart délirant entre le salaire brut
et le salaire net en réduisant les
prélèvements obligatoires dont nous
sommes les champions
plutôt que de réduire les retraites
fruit d'une vie de travail par leur sous
valorisation ou la hausse de la csg et y
est enfin de courage de mener une
réforme juste de notre système de
retraite oui nous devons tout faire pour
revaloriser le travail et il n'y a pas
de droits sans devoirs si vous êtes
prêts à exiger des bénéficiaires du rsa
15 heures d'activité par exemple dans
nos ehpad qui mentent ne serait ce que
deux présences humaines auprès de nos
aînés alors vous pouvez compter sur nous
ne nous dupont pas la clé du pouvoir
d'achat est là que la france produisent
plus d'emplois et plus de richesses
alors ne tuons pas ce qui reste d'un dut
ce cri d'industrie au nom d'un
écologisme punitif dont le seul effet
est de produire plus à l'étranger ce que
nous ne produisons plus en france nos
importations représentent désormais la
majorité de notre empreinte carbone nous
tuions à la fois nos emplois et notre
planète pour créer les conditions d'une
réindustrialisation carbonée il faut
moins de normes moins de paperasse et
une vraie politique de filières et il
nous faut surtout et il nous faut
surtout madame du premier ministre
retrouver l'excellence nucléaire sans
laquelle l'électricité sera plus chère
et plus dé carbonée que de temps perdu
renationaliser
edf pourquoi pas si ça n'est pas pour
mieux le démembrer
nationaliser les pertes pour privatiser
les profits ça ne peut pas être ça le
projet
enfin arrêtons arrêtons d'être les
idiots du village planétaire toutes les
nations défendre leurs intérêts y
compris au sein de l'union européenne
personne ne défendra les nôtres à notre
place et nous devons enfin sortir de
l'illusion de l'argent magique qui
menace notre souveraineté la réalité se
rappelle déjà nous au terme d'un mandat
qui a augmenté de 700 milliards la dette
publique deux fois plus qu'en allemagne
est nettement moins aux raisons de la
crise sanitaire qu'en raison de vos
choix budgétaires comme l'a rappelé la
cour des comptes
nouveau leurre vous voilà aujourd'hui au
pied du mur avec la hausse des taux
d'intérêt alors revenons au bon sens de
montesquieu la politique fondamentale le
point fondamental de la bonne
administration est simple il ne consiste
qu'à ajuster la dépense avec la recette
tous les entrepreneurs doivent le faire
toutes les familles doivent le faire
votre gouvernement doit aussi le faire
madame la première ministre est là
dessus votre discours nous laisse
interrogatif
les familles et les entreprises
françaises sont toujours aussi accablé
d'impôts et de taxes le taux des
prélèvements obligatoires est le même en
2021 qu'il était en 2016 alors que notre
hôpital est au bord de l'implosion
cullen le niveau de notre éducation
s'effondre et qu'elle ne promeut plus as
le mérite que la justice ne sanctionne
trop peu et trop lentement et qui est de
millions de français sont privés d'accès
à la santé
c'est l'argent du contribuable trop
souvent gaspillée la réalité est là il
est possible et nécessaire de faire
mieux avec moins d'argent public
soyons clair augmenter les effectifs de
soignants ou de magistrats oui mais à
condition par ailleurs de réduire
drastiquement les emplois publics dans
les administrations centrales d'en finir
avec cette bureaucratie tatillonne dans
les quelques 1200 agences de l'état dans
tous ses bureaux qui ont pullulé à
mesure que les services de terrain se
raréfiaient la méthode de la révision
générale des politiques publiques d'il
ya 15 ans n'était peut-être pas la bonne
mais cela ne justice il ne justifie en
rien de laisser filer le nombre
d'emplois publics comme vous le faites
depuis 2010 cette soixante dix mille
emplois supplémentaires dans la seule
faction public faire des économies
d'argent public est possible comme nous
le démontrons dans les régions dont nous
avons la charge
et il faudra et il faudra enfin avoir le
courage de protéger l'argent des
français tout autant contre la fraude
sociale que contre les champions de
l'optimisation fiscale qui abusent sous
vos yeux sous les yeux de bercy de prix
de transfert pour ne pas payer d'impôts
en france nous serons à vos côtés si
vous avez le courage de réduire la
dépense publique inefficace pour réduire
l'imposition confiscatoire du travail y
compris madame le premier ministre
l'imposition des moyens d'aller au
travail c'est à dire des carburants la
taxation des carburants c'est le plus
injuste des impôts parce que c'est
l'impôt qui visent directement et
exclusivement cette france qui se lève
tôt pour bosser qui ne s'en sort plus
cette politique du courage que nous
appelons de nos voeux et la seule apte à
rétablir la cohésion nationale
autour du terme de ces cinq années notre
nation est épuisée fracturée les
français ont envoyé un message du
président de la république l'arrogance
solitaire et le mépris des corps
intermédiaires doit cesser au cours des
cinq prochaines années l'assemblée des
élus de la nation que nous sommes que
nous sommes tous devra être devraient
être entendus et nous les députés
républicains nous avons un combat celui
de la cohésion nationale la cohésion
nationale ce n'est pas un slogan tiède
et vaporeux comme l'est devenu le vivre
ensemble c'est un inlassable combat
animé par l'amour de la france qui n'y
est pas qu'il n'y ait pas une france des
précaires une france des protégés mais
une seule france qu'il n'y ait pas une
france des jeunes et une france des
seniors mais une seule france qu'il n'y
ait pas une franche des métropoles une
france des villages mais une seule
france finit pas une france des usines
une france de start up mais il seul
france qu'il n'y ait pas une france qui
croient au ciel une france qui n'y croit
pas mais une seule france
la france fière de son histoire est sûr
de son destin notre nation n'est ni un
taureau d'individus nine juste à
position de communauté elle est ce que
nous avons en héritage en partage elle
nous dépasse et nous oblige non
seulement nous avons le droit mais nous
avons le devoir de défendre notre nation
et notre mode de vie oui nous voulons
que la france reste la france que notre
nation retrouve son rang voilà le chemin
exigeant sur lequel vous savez pouvoir
nous trouver
je remercie